WITH A ONE HERMAN MANKIEWICZ,
SCREENWRITER,
AND MANKIEWICZ ALL OF A SUDDEN
STARTS GOING LIKE,
YEAH, I WAS--I WAS AT
SAN SIMEON THE OTHER WEEK,
AND ORSON'S LIKE,
YOU HAVE INSIDE INFO
AND--AND LIKE LITTLE JUICY
TIDBITS OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
AT THE HEARST CASTLE?
HE'S LIKE, OH, YEAH.
HE'S LIKE, OH [bleep],
I HAVE AN INSIDE GUY.
DO TELL, DO TELL.
I PARTIED THERE REGULAR.
I'M HAVING DRINKS, SMOKING CIGS,
DRINKING CHAMPY,
HAVING DELICIOUS APPETIZERS
WITH MARION DAVIES
AND DOUGIE FAIRBANKS
AND ALL THOSE PEOPLE, LOVING IT.
HE'S WITNESSING THIS STUFF
FIRST HAND OF [chokes] HOLD ON.
[bleep]
SORRY, WHISKEY BEARD.
[laughs and burps]
OH, MAMA.
BUT THEN HEARST WOULD LEAVE
THESE PARTIES AND GO OUT
AND SPREAD ALL
HIS NEWSPAPERS OUT
AND JUST LORD OVER HIS POWERS,
LIKE I CONTROL MEDIA,
WHICH CONTROLS THE WORLD.
I AM [bleep] GOD.
AND ORSON GOES STOP.
I NEED YOU TO WRITE ME
A SCREENPLAY ABOUT THIS,
AND I AM GOING TO MAKE IT
INTO A FEATURE FILM.
DEAL WAS MADE.
ORSON WELLES KNEW THAT WE NEED
TO KIND OF KEEP THIS TOP SECRET,
AND KEEP IT UNDER WRAPS
BECAUSE OF HEARST.
MANKIEWICZ WOULD POUND
OUT THE PAGES,
ORSON WELLES KEPT ON
READING THIS STUFF,
HE WAS LIKE,
THIS IS AMAZING SCREENWRITING.
THIS IS GONNA BE
THE BEST MOVIE EVER,
LIKE I'M MAKING A [bleep]
KICKASS MOVIE MAN.
CAPICHE?
HE WROTE, PRODUCED,
DIRECTED,
HE STARRED IN IT.
WHEN THE MOVIE WAS COMPLETE,
THE MOST POWERFUL
GOSSIP COLUMNIST OF THE TIME,
SHE SAID TO HEARST, THEY MADE
MARION DAVIES LOOK LIKE
A COMPLETE FLOOZY,
HORRIBLE PERSON.
I MEAN THE--THE WHOLE MOVIE
WAS BASICALLY TRASHING
THE HEARST NAME.
HEARST HEARS ABOUT THIS,
AND HE SEES RED.
HE STARTS THREATENING
ANY NEWSPAPER OUT THERE
IF YOU PUT A REVIEW,
IF YOU PUT AN AD OUT FOR THIS,
YOU'RE DONE.
HE TOLD EVERY MOVIE THEATRE,
IF YOU RUN THIS MOVIE,
WE WILL NEVER PLACE AN AD FOR
ONE OF YOUR FILMS EVER AGAIN.
SO.
HMM, UM.
OH, WHAT WAS I TALKING ABOUT?
- CITIZEN KANE?
- [laughs]
THAT WAS VERY GENERAL,
UM [laughs]
AH, RKO CALLED ORSON WELLES